in Game of Thrones when Khaleesi dragons
blow out fire this is how it happens
okay we're gonna try that blazing wings
challenge and we're gonna talk about our
first kisses we're gonna eat some the
spiciest of the spicy in under three
minutes five five wings three minutes
Eli said he had the third spiciest wing
of this kind and couldn't handle that I
literally ran to the bathroom crying
rubbing my tongue with toilet paper
what's wrong with me I know I don't like
this I know - this hurts and I'm excited
what's the problem let's go for it I'm
ready
[Music]
[Music]
okay her name was Amanda
first grade and I hated her my first
goes in front of Mike it was in front of
my dad into my grandpa should follow me
to my grandma's house every single day
and I hated her guts
I wonder she just grabs me those way
around and gives me the biggest nastiest
Anish on the lips runs away I was in a
play bill hug see blues my boyfriend in
the play he wasn't my boyfriend
real-life he was going off to war and I
was supposed to be his girlfriend and he
licked his lips right before he kissed
me
brad is a kiss me I just looked at like
I made eye contact with my grandfather
and I knew I will never forget this day
because this was my first piss and
Amanda ruined it I was in eighth grade
swimming in the ocean with this guy like
the kind of after like beach summer camp
Oh God I was in seventh day and it was
I've been who I had a crush on and we
were all playing spin the bottle we went
to this like junior high trip and we
kissed in the ocean and I will replace
Finn the bottle and then we waited until
later on each other and then we went
back I made out and it was like I just
put on lip gloss feel like the first
time I'd ever wear lip gloss and I just
remember being so wet and like okay you
kissed in the ocean I can send the
oceans pretty romantic sounding like
steps I freaked out and I just swear
way you like someone and then all of a
sudden you just get so scared of the
situation yeah oh my god do it this is
really telling I really am gonna take
this to my therapist I want to eat more
wings but I might do so much pain this
isn't that bad and then it turned
terrible it's all birds I feel [ __ ]
accomplished I'm beside I know thank you
it hurts worse honestly I think that
made the talking made it worse for me
because I don't do it I think my teeth
are gonna fall out that is not where the
teachers
[Music]